what is a lowbudget movie lowbudget
movie it's so hard to Define what a
lowbudget movie is because sometimes you
see something that was made and it's
like $10 million and that is way low
budget for Hollywood but is that low
budget like you and I could afford to
make a $10 million film feature film I
don't think so but it is considered
lowbudget so Kota that won the Academy
Award this year is a lowbudget filmm
that was made for $10 million but that
was obviously a finance film it wasn't
out of her own pocket that she made that
film um there are people who can make
films out of their own pocket many years
ago but is still a prime example is
Robert Rodriguez um El Mariachi that he
made for $77,000 that he earned the
money by selling his body to science
very famous story you know he's written
an entire book about it but he made an
entire feature film shot on film uh for
$7,000 I I know a lot of people have
made feature films for like 10 11,000
five $15,000 but that's not shooting for
a long time that's shooting for a very
limited time in very limited locations
um and it's not going to compete with
with a Hollywood film whatsoever it's
going to feel very much um you know like
there isn't a lot of money there and
hopefully there's some kind of story
that just has to be told and the
filmmaker couldn't wait around to try to
get real funding for it so they just
made it themselves you know they like
but hook or break crook this is getting
made with whatever money I can raise
hopefully maybe by you know Kickstarter
or something like that U but whatever
money I can make for us we're going to
make this film and that's what I
consider like a it's not low budget at
that point it's no budget that's always
the term you use it's like no budget
film um but there are levels there you
know and sag has different agreements
for how much money you know there's a
ultra low budget low budget no micro
budget Etc there are um official terms
for like what money categories are but I
think um most filmmakers if they're
doing it themselves are kind of doing it
on the no-budget school how is a $1
million movie a lowbudget
film well I know $1 million sounds like
a lot of money but it isn't $1 million
is you know can go goes away in a second
and that that remember that 1 million is
not just C covering production it's
post- production as well um so you know
and if you're using paying for locations
and paying for people and you have to
pay for people when you're making a
feature film even if you're shooting it
as quick as you know um 11 days or 18
days paying for people paying for
locations paying for
food eats up a lot of money so um you
know I don't have a million dollars so
I'm not making a million dollar film
um I know a lot of filmmakers it took a
long time to be able to raise that kind
of money um but when they were able to
raise that money they made films that
did get attention you know usually on
the festival circuit trying to but It's
Tricky on the festival circuit now too
it's very hard to get the festival
circuit to program a film that it has to
be really exceptional that has no stars
in it that was made for no money uh you
know we live in the world unfortunately
now where there's too much content so um
you know you have to have a reason why
people should watch your million-dollar
film and hopefully the reason is you're
very unique Storyteller but I tell
people this all the time we're kind of
waiting for the next Quint Quinton
Tarantino to arrive there hasn't been
anybody for a long time that just
radically blew everybody away for a film
that they made with nobody no money and
no stars but they had such a unique
voice so you know that's what we're look
we're looking for that really unique
person that comes through has something
super interesting to say and it's
telling it in a very unique way and
blows us all away with what they want to
do and quite often what is is people are
just doing Hollywood movies or Hollywood
TV shows cheap and that's what they want
to you know they funded it themselves
and they can totally do it but it's not
special or unique or worth our while
watching well you know I I know you're
an Elvis fan and you've written a book
about Elvis so if we took the same
analogy uh for for we're waiting for the
next Elvis right I mean there's so many
quote unquote Elvises now I think it's
harder to sift through completely kind
of spoiled that's it takes a lot of
money to launch somebody to make them
you know so Billy ish who my niece adors
it's like that took a she was self-
produced and all this kind of stuff but
it took a lot of money to launch her so
the fact that she's doing Arena tours
and things of that sort it's not a cheap
cheap thing to um to become
internationally known so it's there's
just too much content now what are three
keys to making a lowbudget
film uh well it's what you can achieve
in with that money um I just like with
short film I don't think you should be
so ambitious that you have to do like a
really low rent version of what you can
do I think you should make something
spectacular with the money that you have
so you want to look carefully at what
you can do with that money also it's a
big commitment I often and I'm coming
from someone who loves shorts I would
recommend you do a killer short versus a
weak Feature lowbudget Feature people
it's hard enough to convince them to
watch your fabulous 8 minute short to
convince them to watch your uh 90minut
feature is asking a lot it has to be
really special and unique uh and when
those show up people are super excited
about but I I ask you you tell me how
many one well you've seen them on TV but
you know how many $1 million do films
have you paid money to go see in the
theater um well I don't know if they
were one million they might have been a
little more but I I do appreciate you
know art housee Cinema I know I'm not
supposed to say that word I'm sorry I do
I say
too but you
know you're right I I I'm actually more
geared toward a lowbudget film than I am
some big Hollywood tent pole the the
amazing because I teach lowbudget film
making um the amazing thing last year
the films that got nominated for the
Academy Award because it was the
pandemic year and because they didn't
Hollywood didn't want to put their
expensive films out in the theater they
were amazingly low budget of the films
that were all nominated I mean Nomad
land things that kind of film they
weren't one million doll films but
manari I think was very close to a
million dollars so there were a lot it
was a nice category last year that there
were a lot of films that were made for
very little money um drive my car this
year I think was made not an American
Film but you know made for very little
money too so there it is amazing
sometimes when these $1 million films
can go as high as being Academy
nominated and you're like oh look what
they did with a million dollars truly
impressive what are some strategies that
anyone can use to break down a
screenplay and analyze a
budget locations is a big part because
you know if you're going to be moving a
lot of locations that takes a lot of
time so quite often you'll see for
lowbudget films they're set in a few
locations and they don't move that much
plus you have to actually secure those
locations so that's why you see a lot of
lowbudget films that are shot in
somebody's home because you can shoot in
your own home you know you don't have to
move around you can shoot in different
parts of your home and get a lot of
production that way you see a lot of
them shut in cars same thing it's very
easy to be driving and filming and it
looks nice and there's motion and things
like that um so you got to think about
how many locations there are how many
actors there are um how long it's going
to take you to actually shoot it those
are the kind of three big things that
kind of delve and how expensive it's
going to be
and how many films can you think of that
were successful in one location I mean
you can think of tape that that was
excellent you know but you'd be
surprised how many things are kind of
set in the house that you didn't even
think about it that it was set in the
house there's a great film called the
invitation um Karen kusama's film that
was like you know it's kind of a horory
or ther kind of film and they're all
brought to be at the house um that's
kind of a traditional um you know
everyone gets murdered in the house kind
of film type of thing um and there's a
lot of films you haven't seen that are
truly just talking people in a
house what tips do you have for
maximizing onscreen value so you know
everything the money should really be
spent so it looks great on screen uh one
of the things that I always tell my
students uh when I teach low budget film
making is white walls are a big Bugaboo
that they look um they look cheap White
Walls totally look cheap uh and it makes
everything look terrible so as much as
like I can shoot for free in my kitchen
well if all those cabinets are white and
it just it it'll look incredibly cheap
where it's so easy to hang a backdrop or
put some you know make some artwork or
whatever and have that in the backdrop
the camera loves detail the camera loves
a lot of things uh to look very full so
uh there are tricks you know to make
things look more expensive than they are
um and also think about what you have
access to that is more expensive than
you would that somebody else would have
to pay for so you know if you want like
if the character has to have an
expensive car but you don't actually
have an expensive car who do you know
who has an expensive car who would lend
it to you for the day you'd be surprised
how many people you know who have things
that could contribute to the production
value and when you say artwork you say
make artwork that is a key right there
not using anything that's copyrighted
you have to be very careful what what
you're doing and and someone think like
oh well let's shoot a scene in the bus
well if you don't have the rights to
shoot in the bus and later on especially
for a feature film feature film you
dream is the feature film is going to
get distributed in some way so
everything has to be cleared in the
feature film and you can't do as many
risky things as you can with the short
because short nobody's cares nobody's
going to make money we can do whatever
you want to do more or less but for a
feature the dream is to have this re
released into the public so you are in
control of everything in a narrative
film you need to make sure that
everything is cleared and everything is
done properly and you have releases and
all that kind of stuff there's no excuse
to be like oh well we were friends so I
didn't have them sign anything and then
later on the whole chain of title falls
apart because you didn't have all you
didn't have your script copyrighted you
didn't do this you didn't do that um and
then your film becomes problematic how
would you budget a $50,000 movie can you
give us a breakdown so don't think of it
all as the production part because post
production counts so much so I would
definitely think about what kind of
access do you have for stuff in post-
production and then what kind of post-
production are you going to need to
spend money on because what people often
do is they just blow it all on
production it used to be called getting
it into the can when it was actual film
Ro reels that would be put into the can
then you have to worry about developing
it and all that kind of stuff we still
use that term in the can of like okay
you finished shooting but now what do
you do and they often just stole all the
money they had for post production
because you desperately needed it for
production just start spending it
because you needed to and all of a
sudden it's like and now there's post
and there's no money in it so I would
definitely recommend of that money post
production is so important and adds so
much and you can get so many things for
free in production that you can't get in
post so I would definitely I would say
even if you want to cut that money in
half and put half for production and
half for post knowing again you're
probably going to steal some of that
money from post when you get in trouble
in production because it's just sitting
there and you always think I can earn
more money later on um but so I would
truthfully split in half and be like
okay half of that's going to be for
production uh post- production and if
you're going to send this off just with
a like with the short if you're going to
send it off on the festival circuit you
should have some marketing money set
aside too so make make that combination
post slm marketing money and spend only
25 on production and then you have to
think of like okay well how many days
are we going to shoot because even we
just ballpark it if you say like even if
I spent no money in pre-production and
know just in in production well if I'm
shooting you know 25 days well now I
only have $1,000 a day and what it's
that starts dividing up into this and
that and that it's like well that's no
money so mostly short mostly low
production films shoot less days because
then you can have more money per day but
for $50,000 film depending on what your
situation is I would think you're
shooting maybe 12 days as opposed to 18
days and then let's suppose you say well
judging the film probably won't get into
any major festivals it's a short so I
just want to go to local ones with my
friends so how much would you say
theoretically to put aside for festival
budget well so actually we for short
films we often really recommend doing
local produ local festivals because
that's you know where you know people
and you can have your film seen by
people who know you and you can go to
the Festival because you're there um but
you still want to try to submit it to
other places so there's application fees
and then there's travel fees when you do
it so I often kind of say to filmmakers
well let's say you know let's say you're
going to try just as a bad average but
like 30 festivals you might apply to and
average out $30 per application for
short film feature films are more
expensive for festivals um and you know
some are going to cost more some are
going to cost less some might uh but
that gives you kind of a ballpark of how
much you might spend and then you want
to budget at least a thousand or two to
go somewhere at some point if you wanted
to um but if you're local then that's
even better uh and you know hopefully
you won't spend that much money at all
is there any way to get a bigname actor
for a $50,000 budget so here's the thing
about bigname actors for both a short
and for a feature everybody always wants
to work and you know especially if
you're a sag shoot so they can work if
they're a sag actor they um in theory
your project you were so special and
your project is so special and they can
get on the ground floor of getting to do
something that's unique so I used to
work for a casting director many years
ago and he'd say about certain actors
like they're great cop number two well
cop number two you recognize that face
because they've been a great cop number
two forever but they want to be not
necessarily cop number one but they want
to be the Romantic lead or whatever and
so here's an opportunity for them to be
the not cup number one cup number two
they get to be the the Romantic lead and
so they will want to do your short or
your feature if you can have access to
them the problem is they are also though
used to being on this TV show where
they've had the trailer and the hours
are such and the food is
such I always make the joke of like
they're not so good about changing
clothes in the Burger King restroom
whereas you know your friend from film
school is totally up for that but these
people have are used to a certain level
of uh professionalism that they might
not be at the same level that you are so
that's something to think about you know
is this something it's always should be
everyone should be making the same film
and the person who is you know used to
TV money is not the same person who's
happy to change in the Burger King
restroom um so that's one thing to
consider also do you have access to
these people you know um but you know
maybe you're in an acting class with
somebody who is an actor of note and you
do have access to them and they know you
and you know they like to do all these
different things why wouldn't you want
to have this actor who's really talented
versus somebody who you know you've
never heard of and have no idea how good
of an actor they are um and there's talk
talk about hook or interest a festival
is more likely wanting to let's just say
Nicole Kidman was your
aunt Festival is more likely to play a
short film with your Aunt Nicole Kidman
in it um you're pretty much in as long
as the film doesn't suck and if you can
guarantee Nicole will come you're in um
so there's a big advantage of that but
then I always say then it becomes the
Nicole Kidman short and it's all about
Nicole Kidman being there and everyone
wants to talk to Nicole Kidman and if
you made this because it wants it should
be the ow all of a sudden it's not the
you show so that's something to think
about too you know is your film any good
or is it all just because she's in it
and that's all people want to know about
but Hollywood would love to see that
Nicole Kidman shirt festivals would love
to play it you put it online and people
would be interested in seeing it you're
trading on that name sure and sometimes
they don't want to see the you show
until they know kind of who you've
worked with yeah oh yeah so more
inclined to be like uh she can work with
NI Cole Kidman I think she can direct
you know our little uh cop show or
something like that right where are
filmmakers most likely to
overspend shorts are learning experience
for everybody so you don't know what to
spend on and what not to spend on um so
sometimes you don't have the right
access you know or somebody says they
really the cameraman insists that they
really need you to rent this one of our
short films the cameraman was a
commercial director and he wanted this
jib arm um and we're like we're not
paying for a jib arm and he's like I'll
call in favors so we didn't pay for it
but he called in favors but then we had
to wait for the jib arm to arrive and
the jib arm had somebody that carried
the jib and put it all together and
operated it so there was another person
on the set and all of a sudden this jib
arm that we didn't want but he wanted
you know cost us time you know versus
money so that things to think think
about of all these decisions now it made
the film look fabulous and when you see
it I think it was probably worth the
time and money and I didn't pay for it
so um you know in that sense it was
really worthwhile uh we did a lot of
short films with with animals and we
paid for the professional animals um we
didn't know at the time that it worked
that you had to pay from the moment they
left their Ranch to the time they go
back to their Ranch so all of a sudden
it was extremely expensive to have these
professional animals and then one of the
little things that we did my famous
quote from that was we had a short film
that a horse and a Frog and I'm like why
is the Frog more expensive than the
horse and the answer was it's harder to
train a frog than a horse totally
legitimate I completely understand now
yes that is the right answer and now I
understand and yeah we probably might
have had a friend who knew someone who
had a horse that could bring in the
horse or whatever but we probably didn't
have a friend that had a frog that could
do what we needed to do on camera on
time for a two- Day short so yes it was
worthwhile spending money on that uh
frog so you know you could write a short
film start staring a frog you think how
hard could it be for me to go I frogs in
my backyard you know and then you
realize oh my God it is really hard to
make a film starring a frog and uh um so
even with a professional dog it took
longer than we thought it was going to
take that's really interesting I did not
know that hey you could have used Kermit
you could have exactly that's the way to
do it think something different okay so
now we can't afford a professional frog
so how cute would it be not Kermit
because that's copyrighted but uh let's
make our own somebody you know is
probably a puppet person or a craft
person who could put together a unique
fr frog for you and that might be a
different kind of film but I think that
would be a more interesting for film to
have this puppet frog in it and then
also because this is unique property
maybe you've now created a character
that people are super interested in with
this frog and all of a sudden you get
meetings with people who are wanting to
do puppet shows and you have a puppet in
yours and so now all of a sudden you're
getting hired to work for Sesame Street
because you couldn't afford the the
professional animal frog so it worked
out well and it made it different and
unique and yeah yeah what's the best way
for filmmakers to keep their budgets
down save money so Robert Rodriguez was
one of the famous lowbudget filmmakers
that he made a film for $7,000 because
he sold his uh body to science to make
that kind of money and he has a terrific
U making of piece called the 10-minute
film school that I actually show when I
teach because it's so inspiring it's on
YouTube you can easily watch it but he
says the secret to not pay money is to
to not let money go out of hand is just
to refuse to spend money and he has an
example from El Mariachi that they had
two different guitar cases one of which
didn't have um the the fabric on the top
and he's the quote he always says is I
was too cheap to spend a dollar for a
spray can to paint the back of it so
they had to do all this complicated
shooting to get around it but that was
he saved that money for the spray paint
so I'm the style producer like it's only
a dollar go buy the damn campaign to
Let's spray and move on but his you know
every command every penny counted for
him and he sold his body for science for
every dollar for that so just his tip
was just refuse to spend money you find
a creative way to shoot around your
problems and don't spend money and if
you're like me like ah I'll spend a
dollar out of my pocket all of a sudden
it's like oh we don't have money money
for lunch okay here let me spend more
money for lunch and all of a sudden your
credit card bill you leave the film with
why is my credit card bill $122,000
because you kept on spending stuff that
you had to buy so then you should keep
an itemized list so that you really see
it in black and white what you're
spending well you should make a budget
and then you know you can be harsh and
say I'm not going to spend more than
this a big fan of contingency though put
some money for contingency because
things happen and you know you can say
we're not going to spend money but then
something happens and where's the money
for that so we can't control film making
that's what's kind of a miracle about it
animators animators can't animators just
sit there and draw and they control
absolutely everything about it and the
time is what takes time or I'm saying
old fashioned drawing I mean they're
doing on in the computer right they they
it's all just computer stuffed and then
but there's still sound for animation
you still got to deal with sound you
still have to deal with music etc etc um
everything always costs money and you
can spend a lot of time getting people
to let you do it for free and a lot of
part of being a filmmaker is to
communicate and to talk to people and to
convince them that you're doing this
fabulous project and shouldn't they help
you and shouldn't they be along and it's
going to be a great experience and
nobody's getting paid and oh my God the
whole film will come together if you
could just give me this free can of
paint or do you know anybody who has a
free can of can of paint that they could
lend us you know you just have to ask
and put the time into it but that's
where it takes a lot of time uh you
know so you can list out this is what
we're going to need this is how much
we're going to pay per head etc etc but
then something always goes wrong sure
and we can also get caught up in the
spirit of it I think you you know
feeling good and feeling wow this is
going to be amazing let me just go over
this let me instead of going to this
fast food chain let me try this place on
ventur Boulevard that has this great
pizza and I want to really treat
everybody you know I mean that's not a
bad way to spend the money but but also
on the producer Wise It's like oh my God
it's going to take you 20 minutes to go
get that and pull it back and do that
and it's like H this is a bad decision
you know better decision would be just
spend a little bit more money to bring
it here and do this and do that let's
just and you're only making this thing
one the other thing I always tell people
too is when the film plays they don't
put a big sign in front of it says this
film was only made for
$50,000 nobody knows how much that film
was made for the thing that counts is
what's on the screen um so also another
one of my favorite quotes from that I
have in my book that a filmmaker said
was like no nobody ever walks away going
um uh the acting was terrible in that
film but the props were excellent we
spent so much time worrying about the
props it's like the acting is really
everything we should have really good
acting it's so easy to want it to be the
house that looks perfect and spends time
getting the lighting exactly right and
and put that prop right here whatever
but people are watching they forgive a
lot they they want a story well told uh
via storytelling and Via acting and the
supporting elements like sound Etc but
they have no idea how much you spent on
it and all they know is the final
product and the final product should be
something that you feel I mean you've
had to make a lot of artistic
compromises but it should be something
that you feel proud of and you're happy
to send out into the world and people
are thrilled to see and enjoy and film
is forever so this is something you're
sending out for the world forever and
that's how it
exists and so just as with let's say a
feature film there's the sort of taboo
about talking about the budget is there
the same taboo with short films
it's so flexible though because like
let's say I Bartered all this stuff but
then if I had to pay for it it would be
a different budget so something I can
make with my students with my
experiences and people I can call on for
favors is not something that you can
make if we had the exact same script I
could make it for a whole different
budget than you could make it for a
whole different budget and they'd be
different films obviously because it
would be my version versus your version
but it's not fair to compare because if
you're trying to do it for not paying
rate if we're paying rate for everything
then it should be exactly the same and
fair and equal but still my talent is
different than your talent you know and
I would pick different actors than you
would pick and if money was nothing look
how many films are made for tons of
money and they totally suck because
people didn't care about the story or
didn't have the they weren't filmmakers
and they weren't storytellers that's
what counts so you know budget SCH
mudget you know it's like again you're
making something that's permanent and
it's out there and it's being shared and
you're not going to get to remake it or
whatever um this is something that
exists and you should be happy with what
you did and you can also forgive
yourself for a lot saying it's a
learning experience and you know I
learned a lot from having made that and
a lot of people when they look back at
their early work cringe you know they're
like their short film sucked their
feature film sucked but I actually went
to an event for Christopher Nolan for
his first feature film following um
which got re-released and he was like
look I'm still talking about following
all these years later he's done all
these huge films I love that following
was so fabulous and again people love
that film but he's like this still F
still following me around he still has
to he's still talking about him doing
yeah so you know but but last but not
least suppose you're lucky enough to get
into a festival you're up there with a
Q&A and then you get the guy all right
question okay what was your budget and
you're like okay do I tell them the
truth so for feature films the reason
why you don't tell them the truth is
because there's a implied value for it
later on you know and you want if if
there's a bidding war for it and they
know you only paid a million for it
they're not going to say and we're
giving you 25 million you know it's like
they're way over spending at that point
for what the value of the thing actually
is so you just don't tell them you know
it's like how much do you want to pay
for it what does it matter how much I
paid for for a short film I think it's
just so many favors and all that that
what's the point of telling people how
much it costs I think people often ask
because they want to kind of figure out
C can they do it you know like if I had
if you made that for $1,000 then maybe I
could make it for
$1,000 um and if there isn't really a
market for it what does it hurt for you
to say $1,000 but I think more
interesting is to say how how many days
you shot or something like that because
you can say okay I see what a 18-day
shoot looks like or I see what a two-day
shoot looks like and I see what a Fed
day shoot looks like and I guarantee you
if I showed you what a film that was
shot for five days and two days you
would totally see what you get
difference not just budget but you know
everything what the difference is so to
me it's more like days but so if
somebody ask a question you just you
just say oh my God we got so many things
for free and I and now you spin it into
your own way like the politicians don't
want to answer and I want to thank
everybody here this theater filled the
people who gave me things for free and I
want to take this opportunity to thank
you for your contributions this film is
not just all about me this film is about
all of us and that's sincere too it's
not just you know politicians kissing
ass